You know, one of the things I was thinking about
yesterday, as we saw the second impeachment of
Donald Trump, is that for a guy who has been
focused on being a winner, winning, winning,
winning and wanting to be the alpha and wanting to
be the big dog and wanting to be respected in all
of this stuff, there's really been no bigger loser
than Donald Trump from the standpoint of American
presidents and what he's done to his party and
what he's done to the country. Donald Trump,
as we mentioned earlier, has now been impeached
twice. No president has ever been impeached twice.
Donald Trump lost the popular vote
twice, something no president has done
in more than 100 years. It has happened
before, but it's been more than 100 years.
Donald Trump's presidency oversaw the loss of
the House of Representatives for Republicans
in twenty eighteen, lost the House. Trump's
mishandling of the virus has been not only
historically disastrous, but it, combined
with his wackiness, led Republicans to lose
the Senate in 2020. And it led to Trump losing
the presidential race and making himself a one
term president. Trump has been widely banned from
social media for completely flouting the rules of
those sorts of social media platforms. And in so
doing all of this, Donald Trump has also damaged
his own businesses, possibly irreparably losing
contracts with the city of New York, many of his
businesses decimated, as we've discussed, and will
lead to investigations of Trump's businesses for
possible financial wrongdoing. He has destroyed
the reputations of his children, his son in law,
and so many of the people around him. Possibly
irreparably, and all of that talk that Trump
always says, you know, no one's ever seen anything
like this, like nobody's ever seen before, we've
gotten used to that phrase. He's right. It's true.
Trump is right about that. But unfortunately,
the superlatives and unprecedented elements of
this presidency are all bad. And unfortunately,
a lot of the awakening that we're seeing didn't
happen sooner. A lot of the damage was done
by the time this partial awakening happened. But
I think it's also important for us to understand
that most Trump events have not abandoned Trump.
There's some good new polling data that came out,
I believe it was yesterday, maybe
this morning. I saw it this morning,
which shows that although 10 Republican members
of the House did vote to impeach Donald Trump,
although some senators are saying Trump should
go, Pat Toomey, for example, we've heard critical
comments from Mitt Romney and some Republican
voters have abandoned Trump. By and large,
Trump continues to be supported by the Republican
electorate and he continues to be seen as
arguably the most dominant and important force
in the Republican Party. So the idea that on
Wednesday at noon, Trump becomes irrelevant to
American politics or to the Republican Party,
so far it doesn't appear to be that way. Yes,
members of the House and Senate of the Republican
Party will, as I have told you, start to distance.
They will go back to saying we've got to focus
on debt and deficit and religious freedom and
lowering taxes and cutting regulations and all
of this stuff. And they'll sort of pretend Trump
never happened or certainly that they weren't
being supportive of it. But for now, the majority
of the Republican electorate is sticking with him
and it's unclear whether there are going to be
consequences and accountability for everything
Donald Trump has done. Incredibly, we know that
Trump still thinks he did a great job. He has
weaponized his narcissism, and that's exactly
why he still thinks he did a great job. He thinks
none of this stuff is his fault. He believes he's
the best. When Trump says I'm the best president,
I've done more than anybody else. He clearly
believes it. And it shouldn't be ignored
that despite all of the losing, Trump has gotten
things done permanently and all of them are bad.
The judges, the court appointments, the that's
irreversible. They Trump will leave. They will
stay continuing to damage the country. And much of
that is thanks to Mitch McConnell and many of the
very Republicans that are now distancing. They put
in Trump's just judges and justices and the time
lost with climate and the environment. There's no
way to get that back. That's irreversible. We can
now try to do even more to make up for
it. But every lost day, we never get back.
But Trump's greatest act, or maybe better said his
strongest action to make America great or greater
is only six days away, which is going to be Donald
Trump leaving office arguably as the biggest loser
to ever be the president of the United States.
We'll have more on this on our Instagram page
at The David Pakman Show. And you can
also find me on Instagram at David
Pakman, The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman dot com.